ciao e benvenuti a tutti questa è
un'inferenza attiva flusso ospite 28.1 è
il 14 ottobre 2022.
oggi ascolteremo e
discuteremo di ripensare la razionalità di
Giovanni Rolla, quindi Giovanni grazie
mille per esserti
unito a questa presentazione e
discussione, quindi via a  grazie
grazie grazie allora è stato un piacere
ricevere il tuo invito un paio di
mesi fa e sono felice di essere qui
per avere l'opportunità di discutere il mio
lavoro
um risparmierò la tua richiesta
um il nostro suggerimento Sto presentando
questo  articolo che ho scritto un paio di anni fa
e mentre stavamo parlando nel backstage
ce l'ho Ho cambiato idea un paio di
volte e lo chiarirò
durante la presentazione da quando ho
pubblicato quel documento ma è un
piacere  comunque avere la possibilità
di presentare questo video qui e uh di
condividerlo con il mondo quindi sono molto
felice
uh quindi parleremo di
ripensare la razionalità e questo è il
questo è l'
itinerario  Stavo pensando di
presentarti, quindi prima
parlerò di razionalità e
cognizione senza contenuto, poi presenterò il
mio punto di vista che ho chiamato
razionalità radicalmente inattiva e parole di sicurezza
sull'azione e l'interazione competente
e il ragionamento e la razionalità sono
vicini a una coppia  di obiezioni la
prima è che
qualunque cosa io sia presente qui è un vero
liberale in un modo eccessivamente liberale
comprende troppo e la seconda
obiezione che penso sia quella che
potrebbe interessarti di più è
se è compatibile con gli effetti  con il
processo predittivo nella nostra codifica predittiva che
è ovviamente nella struttura è
vicino alle due macchine al centro da
fare per esercitare un'influenza attiva,
quindi
ecco il mi dispiace,
il mio pensiero iniziale sull'argomento è
che tradizionalmente gli
ortodossi  avere un punto di vista sulla razionalità
uh presuppone per la maggior parte delle mie conoscenze
che sia davvero un presupposto che la
razionalità deve nel loro ragionamento
che per inst  ance Credo che B in
un'azione a siano razionali se e solo se
c'è il ragionamento che sottoscrive
il Bure così e ovviamente non è solo
un ragionamento che la domanda di ragionamento
deve acquisire con certi
parametri formali come uh
logica classica o ragionamento probabilistico o
l'euristica in modo da credere e agire
razionalmente secondo questo film tradizionale
richiede il rispetto di determinati standard formali
e questo, come ho detto, mi sembra in
gran parte un presupposto su cosa
significhi essere razionali nel definire la
razionalità in termini di ragionamento,
quindi se la razionalità richiede ragionamento
e  se il ragionamento implica la valutazione
delle convinzioni rispetto a determinati
parametri di riferimento formali, la razionalità implica il
contenuto per la cognizione
laddove il contenuto ritengo abbia condizioni minime di
accuratezza in grado
di essere
giusto o sbagliato o in o in una
nozione più ponderata essere vero o falso, quindi
il  l'idea qui è che la razionalità
implica necessariamente il contenuto, implica le
credenze  ragionamento e confronto o
scusa
per aggiornare in questo momento
un aggiornamento software Mi dispiace c'era
un pop-up nella mia finestra qui quindi
um
penso che la visione standard
della razionalità
e
se è così che la razionalità
implica necessariamente  contenuto è una buona misura
con il cognitivismo classico o il
cognitivismo in generale,
che è l'opinione che la combinazione
implica necessariamente un
contenuto rappresentativo almeno per alcuni
cognitivisti, ovviamente potrebbe coinvolgere
anche
un contenuto concettuale ma
almeno un contenuto rappresentativo che ha
condizioni di accuratezza
ma questa visione classica non è così
buona da non fornire un adattamento così buono con la
cognizione radicalmente inattiva e incarnata
che sto qui e non penso
specificamente al radicale e all'attivismo di
Goodwin Maine nei libri recenti, ma
penso che sfidi anche altri  opinioni
che non sono presentate come radicalmente e
attive, ma ovviamente condividono alcuni
inquilini principali con radical e activi  sm
potremmo chiamarli uh visioni radicalmente incarnate
di cognizioni come
um con le opinioni presentate da Ezekiel
Powell o la
vita del modello sensoriale di Berman hai anche
la varietà di inattivismo di Gallagher nel suo
libro del 2017 e anche il punto
di vista di Tony Kimero nel suo  Libro del 2009 sulla
psicologia ecologica e sui
sistemi dinamici condividono tutti inquilini comuni
ed eccomi qui, so che è molto
controverso, ma sto trattando quei
punti di vista come visioni della cognizione radicalmente incarnate
e ma sono specificamente
concentrato su visioni radicali e attive della
cucina
dicono tutti che il riconoscimento non è contenuto
rappresentativo, il che è in
un certo senso che possiamo pensare a
forme di cognizione di base senza contenuto
o a un livello di base di riconoscimento a livello senza contenuto
che emerge attraverso l'
esplorazione attiva del proprio ambiente e
oltre il radicale e l'attivismo di  quello che
intendiamo dire
potrebbe essere questa idea potrebbe essere
incassata in termini di padronanza degli impegni motori sensoriali
una questione di conoscenza  -come
il saper interagire con l'
ambiente circostante invece di sapere che le
cose sono così e così intorno a te quindi questo
è molto chiaramente ciò che Paulo e
colleghi e uh kimero per esempio fanno
nei loro libri uh radicale e l'attivismo
ha una certa tendenza a distorcere
impegni di modelli sensoriali schemi di modelli sensoriali
Etc
e uh,
ma i recenti sviluppi penso abbiano
incorporato che quindi questo è
l'uso dell'essenza di questa idea,
quindi se combiniamo visioni incarnate radicali
di ruminazione o radicalità e attivismo
e il classico carburante su  razionalità
ciò che abbiamo è qualcosa che l'angolo ha
descritto come segue
un attivismo è la visione che la cognizione
è fondata su una
comprensione razionale del mondo di preghiera che si basa
sull'acquisizione sensoriale motoria della
situazione della vita reale
e spiega questi uh questa idea di
pre-  comprensione razionale
da parte di
um
da parte di le idee di melopentin
Heidegger secondo il quale il rapporto
con il mondo può essere solo un radicamento in
p  la pratica degli inattivi nella recitazione e nella
pratica dello stagista è mediata attraverso
il corpo, quindi ciò che sembra essere implicito
qui è che, a differenza della recitazione e della pratica, la
razionalità non è in
realtà è qualcosa che non è a un
livello di combinazione molto semplice, quindi questo è
quello che è successo quando noi
fare spazio a un livello base di cognizione
radicata nell'attivo e nella pratica e
separarlo dai livelli superiori di
combinazione che di solito sono il
luogo il classico fortunato della razionalità
quindi
l'idea in sintesi è quella
cognizione controversa o cognizione di base
che emerge attraverso i sensi  gli
impegni motori non sono razionali
così sensoriali gli impegni moderni tuttavia le
virtù in prolifici non possono
essere valutati dal punto di vista della
razionalità solo contenuto per la cognizione
combinazione di alto livello può essere
definizione razionale che è espressa ad
esempio in credenze e recentemente
e bene questo è qualcosa  che
non ho toccato sulla carta ma
era la mia motivazione implicita a d  bene con
questo argomento
come qualcuno che viene dalla filosofia
della mente è l'idea del mito del
dato almeno una versione di
esso mi sembrava in quel momento e uh sono stato
correttamente persuaso da un recensore a non
toccare l'argomento  era molto
contorto nella mia presentazione iniziale,
ma mi sembra che se dividiamo il
riconoscimento di base da un pensiero
e un'azione razionali e non puntiamo verso
il
pozzo non ci sia un'intersezione
tra questi due livelli, sembra che
radicale e attivismo e  uh
opinioni simili sarebbero impegnate nel mito
del dato impopolare da Sellers e
moderazione da McDowell come un problema per i
campi imperiosi della
mia mente quindi sembra che questo sia
un problema filosoficamente interessante,
ma non è qualcosa che è  uh in prima
linea nel documento è stata la mia
motivazione implicita qui quella di spiegare
come possiamo combinare il
livello di cognizione senza contenuto o di base attraverso
impegni sensoriali moderni con la ratio  nalità se
non puoi sembra che ci sia un
dato di qualche tipo che non è stato
completamente spiegato nella nostra immagine
della mente quindi questo è qualcosa che
volevo Voglio ancora provare a esplorare
questa questa intuizione più chiaramente ma ho
Non ho toccato questo ehm, ma penso che ci sia qualcosa nella
direzione del perché quello che mostrerò
oggi è che penso sia un modo per sminuire
questa accusa di essere impegnato
nel mito del dato,
quindi come possiamo riconcepire la razionalità
intendo  Penso che per evitare questo
problema ed evitare l'idea che abbiamo
due livelli completamente separati l'
uno dall'altro in cui uno Il Superiore è
il luogo della razionalità classica e
cos'altro c'è al di sotto non è razionale
Penso che l'idea sia rifiutare la
razionalità  deve essere definito o
comporta necessariamente un ragionamento
non ha bisogno di essere ancora concepito ma
allora la sfida diventa quella di offrire una
proposta positiva di cosa sia la razionalità se non il
ragionamento ed ecco Susan H  urley in un
articolo che la mia conoscenza è l'unica
su questo argomento e penso che anche lei fosse
preoccupata per il mito del
dato tra l'altro in quel momento e lui è una
lunga citazione da qui phenomide me la
lettura è quella razionalità  potrebbero
emergere da un complesso sistema di
gerarchie centralizzate relazioni di
inibizione facilitazione e coordinamento
tra diversi strati orizzontali Ciascuno
dei quali è una razionalità dinamica e ambientalmente
situata ripensata in
termini orizzontali o modulari ehm non
so se deve usare questa
terminologia ma  in ogni caso è così che ha
scelto di esprimere è
legato in modo sostenibile all'ambiente non
dipende solo da procedure interne che
mediano tra input e output come il
contenuto o per l'organismo nel suo
insieme o per un
modulo cognitivo centrale delimitato verticalmente piuttosto
dipende da  complesse relazioni tra
Mondo dedicato che coinvolgono livelli che
monitorano e rispondono ad aspetti specifici
del n  ambiente naturale e sociale
e della rete neurale e ridurre il
loro feedback dalle loro risposte questo,
a mia conoscenza, è il primo caso di
qualcuno che lavora sull'approccio inattivo
in un
modo ovviamente più
solitamente associato al lavoro di
avano che è anche un attivista ma
in un approccio diverso dal radicale e
dall'attivismo ed ecco il primo
e che io sappia prima di scrivere quel
documento è che la proposta più chiara
di razionalità ripensata
nei termini nativi ma non è
qualcosa che ha preso piede
dopo la sua pubblicazione su  la mia conoscenza in
realtà non ho visto molto da allora
e per riassumere l'idea è che
dobbiamo cambiare il Focus esplicativo
che è la razionalità non è
pensata esclusivamente come un Contenuto che coinvolge la
capacità in questa proposta è situata
o Mondo coinvolto in mondi aumentati
ed è radicalmente incarnato
dipende dalla morfologia e dall'azione del corpo
e da come l'organismo è situato e
agisce  s in quell'ambiente l'idea
sarà minimamente morta, quindi questo è ciò che chiamo
razionalità radicalmente
inattiva è in una
definizione molto vaga finora è che un'asiatica
agisce razionalmente nella misura in cui l'essere umano
mantiene un'interazione competente con il
suo ambiente coordinando le sue
capacità cognitive  in base a
condizioni ambientali di vincoli
e solide stazioni e ovviamente questo a
volte richiede un adattamento a
circostanze impreviste l'
intuizione fondamentale è questa
ed è interessante confrontare questa
idea di razionalità radicale e attiva
con un'altra delle idee di Susan Hurley in
un testo del 2003 di cui è  dice
ragioni per agire che sostiene
che le ragioni per agire possono essere
legate al contesto in cui sta discutendo contro il
vincolo di generalità di Gareth Evans
e questa è la difesa dell'idea di
isole di razionalità pratica,
quindi sta ancora trattando la razionalità come
qualcosa che riguarda essenzialmente  al
ragionamento qui, ma questo tipo di
ragionamento è limitato  d dal
contesto pratico quindi questa è una visione molto progressista
se confrontata con la visione tradizionale di
cui ho parlato all'inizio
ma è ancora più conservatrice di quella che
sto cercando di sviluppare qui
quindi un'altra cosa che penso debba essere
lì in prima linea di questo  la proposta
è che la razionalità implichi l'agenzia e l'
autonomia perché qualcosa o solo
qualcosa che un organismo fa si può
dire razionale,
quindi usare queste idee dal
campo autonomo e attivista e
dalla teoria di come giocare sono
sistemi autonomi come  un Roomba
non può essere razionale perché non è un
agente non è l'autore del proprio
comportamento è progettato da
agenti esterni per funzionare in un certo modo quindi
non è in senso stretto una nazione, quindi
è lì che traccerei la linea di dove
bene  non può non ha senso
attribuire razionalità ad un Roomba ad
esempio
e
per
questo utilizzo le Nozioni di autonomia e
adattabilità il DiPaolo e altri tu
hai un  anche il libro recente raffigura i
quattro modelli sensoriali di vita e quella famosa
carta dalla ciotola del 2005 in cui
parla dell'adattabilità
per stabilire i suoi vincoli molto generali
su cosa significa essere russi,
quindi i sistemi autonomi sono quindi
concepiti come reti precarie un
rete precaria di processi perché l'
organizzazione e i confini fisici sono
prodotti dal sistema stesso il sistema
mantiene continuamente le proprie
condizioni di fattibilità che è
noto come senso che il
sistema ha esplorato
condizioni ambientali ambientali
favorevoli al suo automantenimento e
evita quelli che sono dannosi per
esso,
quindi è così che intendo
essere proprio in generale il
vincolo emotivo su un essere razionale
che deve essere un sistema autonomo
e la cosa interessante qui è che
il concetto di adattabilità che Paulo ma
quarto è che la capacità di un
organismo di migliorare la sua condizione di
autoproduzione attraverso  h
cambiamenti strutturali interni,
quindi implica il monitoraggio e la
regolazione dei cambiamenti interni al fine
di selezionare la migliore linea d'
azione disponibile, penso sia un altro
concetto interessante su cui riflettere per
includere questa idea di una
nozione di razionalità radicalmente inattiva che
non è necessariamente impegnato nel
ragionamento e nel contenuto,
quindi l'agenzia si realizza attraverso l'
esercizio di abilità situate che
promuovono i cambiamenti all'interno dell'organismo in
conformità con i
vincoli e le sottostazioni ambientali, il
che significa che quanto bene un organismo si
adatta per affrontare in modo
efficiente il suo ambiente è una misura  di o
un'indicazione della sua
razionalità più un organismo è razionale più
è adatto a trattare con il suo
ambiente e abbiamo previsto le
circostanze
e così facendo l'organismo accresce
Il continuo scambio tra sé
e l'ambiente
che è determinante per la sua sopravvivenza e
è un
modo molto naturalizzato di pensare alla
razionalità  è principalmente la capacità di
migliorare i cambiamenti per la sopravvivenza
questa è
l'idea generale qui
quindi come ho detto prima che dire del ragionamento
non voglio impegnare
necessariamente la razionalità con il ragionamento ed è questo
ciò che riguarda la razionalità radicalmente inattiva
ma io  non voglio escludere il
ragionamento come una precedente combinazione razionale,
quindi quello che sto dicendo è
che non è definito dal ragionamento ma
non è uh non esclude il ragionamento il
ragionamento penso sarebbe considerato come
una modalità speciale o specifica di
agenzia razionale  uno che è esclusivo della nostra
conoscenza per gli esseri umani
ma non è la caratteristica distintiva della
razionalità
quindi per questo io uh per spiegare
questa idea ricordo come Hutu e
Saturno tra gli articoli nel libro più recente
di utani spiegano il  l'emergere
di un alto riconoscimento l'idea è che
essere in grado di impegnarsi in contenuti per la
cognizione in definitiva dipende dall'essere
socialmente radicati nella cultura in
cui la piena cognizione del contenuto è emersa
da soc  interazione culturale globale così quando
un individuo prende parte
alle pratiche socioculturali
accetta capacità cognitive più antiche
di trattare con i simboli e
così
facendo in un lungo processo di inculturazione
naturalmente diventa in grado di impegnarsi con
un coordinamento simbolico che non è
interno  rappresentazione specifica
perché pubblicamente disponibile non sono
rappresentazioni mentali in senso tradizionale
ma ha le caratteristiche della
cognizione simbolica senza l'impegno per
rappresentazioni interne o rappresentazioni mentali
quindi agire razionalmente nel suo senso più generale
è l'idea che il
comportamento competente di un  l'organismo è in uh è è
il comportamento competente di un organismo
nel suo ambiente dipende dalla
coordinazione delle capacità incarnate
mentre il ragionamento se tutto va
bene ovviamente è inteso come contenuto
della razionalità per il mio specifico modo di
razionalità il ragionamento è il
comportamento competente di un  organismo in un sociale
culturale en  ambiente
che è un aspetto più specifico del nostro
ambiente ovviamente e dipende
dal coordinamento di tali capacità culturalmente
basate o che coinvolgono capacità
che sono più recenti nella
scala filogenetica umana,
quindi questo è il più grande
dell'idea questo è il  la penso
uh la parte propositiva e qui ci sono
le obiezioni di cui volevo parlare
prima essendo che è una visione molto liberale
è molto
uh è bene che comprenda troppo
si direbbe perché se l'azione razionale
si riduce al coordinamento  delle
capacità cognitive quindi la razionalità è
qualcosa di graduale per un organismo potrebbe
essere più o meno abile nelle sue
interazioni ambientali
e il rifiuto va secondo
una razionalità radicalmente inattiva molti
organismi realizzano e mantengono un
comportamento adattivo nella nicchia con
diversi livelli di successo a cui io
sto bene che qualcuno potrebbe cantare razionalità razionali
e attive radicali e attive
a liberale e questo è
un'obiezione che ho sentito di persona
e l'ho tenuta così duramente perché penso
che sia molto, è un ottimo modo per
metterlo anche le unghie sono razionali su
questo punto di vista e quello a cui devo dire
che sono disposto a comprare  il portafoglio
uh beh sì è più liberale
delle opinioni tradizionali ovviamente è
destinato ad essere così ma non penso che
questo problema di per sé quello che penso sia il
la parte positiva qui è che
conserva una differenza di grado in cui gli
esseri umani sono  molto più razionale di altri
animali semplicemente perché siamo in grado di
eseguire un'ampia varietà di azioni in
un'ampia varietà di circostanze dinamiche
che sono ben oltre qualsiasi altro animale di
cui siamo a conoscenza,
quindi per tornare all'esempio di questo
chiodo questo chiodo può  eseguire alcune
azioni complesse può spostarsi da un punto
all'altro può cercare cibo e
riparo e così via ma hanno
una serie limitata di abilità critiche
se circondi questo chiodo con il Sud,
ad esempio è destinato a morire per
la replica e gli umani d'altra
parte sono molto più adattivi e in
grado di affrontare dinamicamente molte
circostanze impreviste, quindi
nella mia risposta a quell'obiezione è che
sì,
beh, è ​​molto liberale ma
non è questo il problema, il problema sarebbe se
quello  lo è se avesse spazio per una
differenza di grado tra il modo in cui gli animali
trattano i loro
ambienti e questa è l'altra
obiezione dell'oggetto che penso possa essere anche
se quella che ti interessa di più, allora
sai che è l'elaborazione predittiva dei 12
sembra implicare inferenze e
contenuti fino in fondo,
ma all'inizio devo avvertire te e
gli spettatori che
al momento in cui ho scritto questo articolo, questo articolo
era molto più ottimista su questa
possibilità di combinare un attivismo e una
codifica predittiva o
un'elaborazione predittiva e uh  Penso che ci siano
punti importanti qui, ma c'è questo
recente articolo di Olu e Evan Thompson
e Randy Beer in cui
forniscono una valutazione critica di uh th
e i tentativi di combinare principalmente
il principio dell'energia libera e
um
teorie inattive e autobiografiche, quindi ora sono per
lo più convinto dalle argomentazioni ma
penso che ci siano alcuni punti
di confronto interessanti qui
comunque processo predittivo nel nostro
codice predittivo e uh al  tempo che stavo scrivendo
e ancora oggi è di gran moda nelle
scienze cognitive, immagino si possa
dire che suonava dolcezza è diventato
uno dei principali paradigmi là fuori,
quindi è interessante vedere se
si adatta bene a ciò che ho  sto parlando
e in questi visori sai che la
concorrenza è intesa come un processo
di minimizzazione degli errori che avviene in
gerarchie ristrette bidirezionali
quindi
hai la generazione di
modelli interni per l'attività degli strati inferiori
che anticipa le cause distali di
stimoli sinistri che è un  processo dall'alto verso il basso
e la minimizzazione della
discrepanza tra la previsione e il
segnale di stimolo attuale mediante
l'occupazione di priori che  è una parte
inferiore del processo,
quindi ecco ovviamente l'inferenza attiva
che è intesa, ad esempio,
in termini formali informali da
Clark che un organismo muove i suoi sensori
in modi che equivalgono a cercare attivamente nella
nostra generazione generando le
conseguenze sensoriali che sono piuttosto  i loro
cervelli si aspettano che
questo sia un modo per comprendere l'
influenza attiva termini molto formali, ma
penso che riesca a fare il lavoro,
quindi il cervello deduce la
fonte prevista di stimoli ricevuti
se sembra che ci sia un
problema con quello che sono  parlando
così, la lettura del voto di lui
dell'elaborazione predittiva che è che utilizza la
distorsione del prodotto e il diritto di inferenza dice
ad esempio che il processo dei
percezionisti è separabile dal
processo di distorsione razionale più ampio di
prolificazione e dagli effetti dall'alto verso il basso del contesto
Ho sentito che ogni
livello intermedio di  l'elaborazione di questo ha attirato la mia
attenzione nel modo in cui Clark parla anche
di razionalità fino in fondo,
ma è un  n tipo inferenziale di
razionalità
e ragionamento pervasivo dell'influencer
sembra implicare un contenuto impervasivo
e quindi l'elaborazione predittiva sembra
essere incompatibile con la razionalità radicalmente inattiva,
ma c'è uh all'epoca
c'era e penso che possiamo ancora discutere in
molti dei non c'è
-emorroidi e lettura
dell'elaborazione predittiva
che utilizza, ad esempio, un primo passo
sarebbe quello di utilizzare un senso deflazionistico di
previsione che comprende il cameo in un
breve articolo del 2013 ma quarto in cui
i valori di due o più variabili
covariano o sono valutati in modo affidabile, quindi il
il valore di 1 consente all'Osservatore di dedurre
il valore di un altro e qui l'
inferenza sta avvenendo a
livello di osservazione non in una
variabile lontana sta deducendo il valore di
un'altra quindi l'idea sarebbe Penso
che il contenuto sia nell'occhio di  l'
osservatore la persona che interpreta come
la selezione di censori che mettiamo
approssima le previsioni interne qui
intese in t  Il senso inflazionistico può
descriverlo in termini inferenziali e di parte
, quindi è così che vedo ad
esempio l'idea di 4 000 dell'articolo di
Bruno che se non sbaglio il
titolo è qualcosa come il cervello non è
uno scienziato e l'argomento è in  questa
direzione generale
che stiamo proiettando su come gli
scienziati interpretano l'attività cerebrale come una
caratteristica del cervello stesso come se
stesse prevedendo e deducendo questo senso più
robusto o più pesante
quindi quello che sto cercando di dire qui è che l'
inferenza attiva quindi uso double  e
dire doppio dimenticato il nome di questo in
inglese scusa
um non è il senso letterale
dell'inferenza qui secondo la
razionalità radicalmente inattiva è che disarmato per l'
efficienza del comportamento co-orientato l'
agente deve agire in determinati modi in
ordine per il suo  i suoi stati si
realizzano in modo più efficiente meno costoso
ciò non implica l'affermazione più controversa
che i modelli generativi
stessi mostrano ed eseguono
inferenza predittiva  es questa è una
lettura molto deflazionistica nell'elaborazione predittiva
per fornire a questa
combinazione una razionalità radicale e attiva
ed ecco un inizio in un documento del
per modello, non ne consegue che un
organismo abbia un
modello rappresentativo interno della sua nicchia in
quanto  è questo modello che quelli sono il
lavoro cognitivo se ti piace invece un
organismo è un modello cioè le
regolarità causali e statistiche riflettono in
qualche ambiente riflettendo qualche
fenotipo che è un modello
e beh
questo si riferisce a qualcosa che recentemente
io e il mio collega notifica  abbiamo
parlato dell'idea di come gli organismi
producano un mondo secondo un
attivismo che è l'idea che l'organismo
e l'ambiente sono
storicamente chiamati determinati, quindi
alla scala genetica del flusso questo potrebbe
essere spiegato attraverso l'idea della costruzione di nicchia
l'idea che una volta  un
organismo è attivo nel suo ambiente
promuove cambiamenti che se sono
sufficientemente stabili th  Possono essere ereditati dalla sua
Progenie e questi cambiamenti forniscono nuove
pressioni di stampa evolutive
che guidano il suo percorso evolutivo
un'idea simile è stata esplorata anche da
un'altra descrizione questa volta relativa alla
costruzione di nicchia
e alla psicologia ecologica,
quindi la mia risposta a tale obiezione è
che agire razionalmente significa raggiungere
un coinvolgimento competente con l'
ambiente attraverso in un certo senso la previsione
e la loro minimizzazione Sono disposto ad
accettare che la caratterizzazione, ma
i processi di bias razionali e più ampi
non devono implicare contenuto per la cognizione
se lo comprendiamo nel Flash  nessuna
previsione sensata e la loro minimizzazione
implicano la selezione di input e il
coordinamento di un'interabilità nei
modi di coinvolgimento del mondo che è
esattamente l'affermazione principale della personalità radicale e
attiva, quindi penso che
fino a quel punto l'elaborazione predittiva non sia
un nemico sarebbe piuttosto  che una bugia
di questa idea invece di uh
arrivo ma di c  ci sono altri
problemi di compatibilità che
non ho toccato qui ma questo è
tutto ciò a cui ho pensato per oggi grazie
fantastico grazie
mille ok
fantastico molto interessante
per coloro che stanno guardando dal vivo per favore
sentiti libero di  scrivi tutte le domande
raccoglierò i miei appunti e iniziamo la
discussione
ok
bene prima ancora grazie ancora per il
discorso
che ne dici di un piccolo contesto su come sei
arrivato a porre queste domande nella
tua posizione attuale e su come si sono sviluppati i tuoi
interessi in quest'area perché
c'è  così tante idee interessanti e
volevo solo saperne di più su come sei
arrivato a questo inquadratura e affinato il tuo
punto
ok grazie questa è una buona
domanda perché non capita spesso di
poter esplorare questo background
è importante quindi lo ero in quel momento
penso che stavo scrivendo la mia tesi di dottorato
, forse era il 2007 o qualcosa del genere e
stavo sostenendo l'idea che la
razionalità debba essere qualcosa che alla
fine è coinvolto nel mondo  c'è una
tendenza a pensare bene anche tra come
ho detto come ti ho mostrato tra uh in
periodi incarnati con persone di
certo, deve essere essenzialmente il
coinvolgimento del mondo come recitazione e pratica
e così via
e percezione ovviamente ma la razionalità
rimane  qualcosa come
nozione naturalizzabile qualcosa che non può
essere ridotto al livello del
non potrebbe essere ridimensionato in un modo
come la percezione che potrebbe essere spiegata
da un certo impegno dinamico e
così via
così all'epoca stavo pensando che bene
forse questo è
un problema al ginocchio perché
in
altri contesti si intende implicare che
qualunque sia la percezione se non è
articolata in modo da fornire un
certo adattamento con la combinazione professionale,
allora la percezione è un dato di fatto
e questo è il mito della
Dimensione data  all'inizio e ho pensato
che forse questo è qualcosa di
c'è qualcosa di un mito del
dato che lavora qui su una
cognizione attiva ma non è questo, penso che
non è fatale perché non potremmo sostenere in linea di principio
che invece di
interpretare la percezione del passo e
altre forme base di combinazioni che
coinvolgono concetti e simili forse
potremmo discutere
dall'altra direzione provare a ridimensionare
la razionalità in un livello più non naturalizzato
di
uh
quindi questa era la motivazione ed è stato
molto, è stato un lungo processo di revisione e
credo che la mia prima versione
del giornale che lo spettatore fosse molto
sono stati molto irremovibili nel prendere quella
parte e penso che fosse per il meglio
perché è un'altra letteratura
è un'altra ehm un sacco di riferimenti che di
solito non sono in conversazione con un
attivismo e il riconoscimento del corpo ed è stato
molto difficile mettere il  importa
negli stessi termini per avanzare le mie argomentazioni,
quindi è qualcosa che ho cancellato
e non ho pensato troppo a
quel sistema, ma penso che sia qualcosa che mi
piacerebbe  a cui tornare e forse uh
anche probabilmente qualcuno l'ha fatto
in questi ultimi anni non mi rendo conto di
poterlo ricordare ma
questa relazione tra un attivismo il
mito del dono e sembrava essere
sembra essere molto
evidente  quindi è qualcosa che
potremmo dovremmo voler dire essere in grado di
esplorare ma non c'è qualcosa che
era in prima linea sul giornale
ma ho avuto questa idea di parlare di
razionalità in ogni senso lampeggiante
e allo stesso  tempo stavo leggendo molto
di uh l'ho
chiamato da una
prospettiva filosofica ovviamente non sono come ho detto
molto esperto dei tecnicismi
e delle formalità dell'approccio
ma ero interessato alle
conseguenze filosofiche lì e ho
pensato bene  forse c'è qualcosa da
confrontare qui perché, come mostra la citazione di Clark,
puoi parlare di razionalità
fino in fondo ed è qualcosa che
volevo sviluppare ma non in una visione cognitivista ma non in un
film radicalmente incarnato, quindi
questo è lo sfondo
fantastico grazie potresti forse
descrivere qual è il mito del
dato qual era il contesto in cui è sorto quel
mito e dove andiamo dopo
aver sollevato il mito del dato
perché l'ho visto come un concetto che  hai
intrecciato quindi di cosa si trattava
bene così nel mezzo del darlo che
bene ci sono diversi dati possibili a
seconda del tuo gusto
della mia filosofia ma più classicamente nei
campi precedenti della mente prendi il
contenuto della percezione da dare  preghiera
razionalmente in modo che abbiamo certi
input che sono appena ricevuti dalla
mente e la mente lo interpreta, quindi
venditori diversi venditori sono famosi per
aver descritto il suo uh questo problema come
un problema non solo per aumentare i combustibili
della mente ma anche  per i razionalisti,
ma d'altra parte, il razionale è
solitamente considerato come un
dato di fatto, il che significa che c'è un
certo livello di cognizione che non è
articolato che "  è dato o come alcune
persone parlano di essere allevato dato
ma in un certo senso c'è questo livello di
cognizione che è dato e la mente
deve interpretarlo ma se è dato in
questo modo non ha punto di contatto nessun
uh intersezione tra qualunque cosa
qualunque cosa faccia la mente e questo
livello di base di dominio, quindi la mia idea è di
evitare l'accusa di essere impegnata
nel mito del dato, ma ancora una volta questo
non è qualcosa che è esplicito nella
letteratura nativista ma è
qualcosa che sembra essere
possibile sviluppare in un
intendo uh in questo tipo di confronto
ma non è dal
non chiaramente lì ma
un modo per risolverli per i Givens
per dire che il contenuto percettivo è
già di natura concettuale,
come ad esempio Joe McDowell  ha in
mente di più che conosci una
percezione uh la battuta è che
ti sottotitola e interpreta il mondo
come fai tu ma
penso che in un modo o nell'altro sia
quello di demistificare conosci una razionalità  e
gli strati superiori della combinazione
provano a pensare a loro uh uh in meno
uh contenuto per l'analisi
senza commetterli, quindi è strettamente
parlando con un livello di contenuto che è
separato dai livelli di base di
combinazione è un modo in cui penso di
farlo e  la razionalità sembra essere l'
unico concetto chiave per farlo
perché di solito si presume che sia qualcosa di
esclusivamente umano e qualcosa che è
correlato al ragionamento e se è
così allora la razionalità non può informare l'azione
e se, naturalmente, se l'azione è
di natura priva di contenuto  quindi se la razionalità
è un senso essenzialmente contenuto e la
reazione è essenzialmente incontenibile per il senza
contenuto, allora puoi non avere
questo
uh che è fatto questa uh intersezione
tra due domini e questo è
qualcosa che volevo evitare ma come ti ho
detto è diventato così difficile da  esprimere
questo punto di vista in modo
sufficientemente chiaro e generale è
che, su raccomandazione del nostro revisore, lo
rimuovo e ci
penso ancora  ma niente,
non ho sviluppato una
linea di argomentazione adeguata che lo affronti in modo
più chiaro di quanto possa fare, come ho appena fatto
in termini molto generali
raffreddare bene alcune parole che hai associato
alla razionalità erano adattabilità
e anche competenza quindi cosa vedi
come il rapporto tra razionalità e
fitness
come funzione biologica giusto sì sì
ok
Penso che sia una
relazione intrinseca davvero penso che sia
probabilmente la conseguenza più
[musica]
um
ovvia dell'azione razionale
su una scala speciale e quando
parliamo se la razionalità è una caratteristica
di certe specie o invece degli
individui penso che l'idoneità sia uno dei
concetti chiave qui per pensare che questo
sia il risultato di questa
azione razionale,
quindi anche se non dico di non
mettilo in quelle questioni sul giornale
Penso che sia possibile pensarlo in questo
modo sai non lo vedi
come un'obiezione a pensare alla
razionalità ma ancora una volta è molto liberale
e sono disposto a t  o accettare anche questa
conseguenza ogni
organismo vivente in un certo modo se non ha
ancora l'Istinto quindi è in un modo
adattato al suo ambiente quindi sono disposto
a vedere che può implicare un
livello minimo di razionalità di  affrontare
il nemico che cambia ambiente
ma bene ed è il prezzo di avere una
nozione molto liberale di
razionalità progressista questa è una conseguenza
di ciò credo
quindi hai detto che l'idoneità è una
conseguenza del comportamento razionale
ci sono altre conseguenze o  come facciamo a
riconoscere la razionalità dall'esterno
se non solo dire bene che la
colonia di formiche sta prosperando così tanto nella misura in
cui è razionale è adattabile
un'agenzia espositiva e tutto
questo è un
concetto di razionalità così deflazionistica che tutte le cose esistenti gli
esseri umani e  altrimenti sono semplicemente
descritti da esso o ci sono alcuni
risultati che possiamo usare per districare
come ad esempio un comportamento razionale o
irrazionale dalle semplici
conseguenze riflesse da su  sopravvivenza e
fitness
proprio bene Ho dovuto pensarci molto
attentamente perché non
voglio banalizzare questo concetto in modo
che tutto sia IPS di fatto o
razionale dal fatto che sta
vivendo sta recitando una relazione ma io
penso che in casi particolari si
potrebbe identificare la nazione in cui sono
uguale agli individui e l'
autosufficienza in quella nicchia quindi quindi
a livello individuale in particolare
va bene questa è una conclusione certe
azioni che potrebbero classificare
irrazionali nella misura in cui
sono dannosi per la sopravvivenza ma
a livello di specie è più
difficile argomentare in quel modo
perché identificare questo tipo di comportamento o
conseguenza ma penso che
per non banalizzare l'idea di
razionale e dire bene tutto ciò che è
vivere è fattorizzato bisognerebbe
identificare questo tipo di atti particolari
che vanno a detrimento
di una sopravvivenza
quindi nel caso del formicaio
non so forse
accogliere gli invasori sarebbe un
comportamento che
pregiudicherebbe la
sopravvivenza in quanto tale
con attenzione
oh molto interessante e hai inserito
quella risposta e nella presentazione
come
scale temporali nidificate multiple, proprio come fa Eco Evo
Devo da una prospettiva più biologica
, guardando come la
costruzione della nicchia Colma il divario tra
processi filogenetici più lenti e
processi di sviluppo più rapidi
ehm, quindi  come si collega questa
considerazione incorporata e
multiscala al
concetto di contenuto come se il contenuto sarà
localizzato in un corpo o il contenuto è
distribuito tra entità o la
razionalità è distribuita tra entità
come potremmo anche identificare il luogo
della razionalità e che  anche in qualche modo
invoca la concezione orizzontale e modulare
dalla citazione che hai
fornito, quindi come possiamo identificare il saliente
scale temporali spaziali e sistemi di
interesse
oh ah non so non so se posso
rispondere a questo in modo completo ma mi sembra
che a livello di uh se stiamo parlando
di contenuto, ad esempio contenuto come
accuratezza  condizioni per i
pensieri simbolici Penso che fortunatamente dobbiamo
dire che non è localizzato in un
singolo individuo è pubblicamente condiviso
quindi puoi dire che
una conseguenza di ciò è che è
possibile pensare a diversi
schemi di ragionamento che sono i
siti di informazione  in momenti diversi Etc e puoi
vedere che hanno sviluppato regole diverse di
livello diverso per le
informazioni sui contenuti
e penso che questo sia
plausibile dire che il contenuto
è localizzato che il
uh come puoi dire che condividi la quantità di
cui conosci le specifiche
solo per razionalità penso che
si potrebbe
[Musica]
identificare in particolari comportamenti
se si adatta a questi uh
questo tipo di descrizione di uh spin
abile abile interazione e
adattivo  interazione tra un organismo
e il suo ambiente la sua nicchia quindi
probabilmente
potremmo dare risposte diverse qui
come razionalità e contenuto Sono disposto
a dire che il
contenuto per l'organizzazione non è
qualcosa che accade nella testa
qualcosa che è là fuori in un certo modo
condividi  la quantità di altri e questo è
qualcosa che la mia filosofia
ha almeno dagli anni '60 i
miei filosofi hanno
sostenuto l'idea che il contenuto sia individuato dall'esterno
e uh penso che questo sia uno
dei video di  per esempio Hillary Putnam
e Tyler Burge e altri che il
contenuto mentale è individuato a
livello di comunità o di società,
ma d'altra parte pensano che la
razionalità potrebbe essere in linea di principio
individuata in comportamenti particolari
ma dipenderebbe dagli
obiettivi dell'individuo e dal  la nicchia in cui abita e
così via
ci sono ovviamente delle variabili effettive
qui che potrebbero essere importanti anche
per identificare il
comportamento  come razionale o no,
grazie,
beh, una frase che mi è rimasta davvero
impressa era come sapere come non sapere che
forse un punto fondamentale nel tuo lavoro
e un focus su quell'azione, quindi volevo solo
sapere come l'azione e la pratica
mentre tessevi  loro qui oggi come vengono
affrontati quei termini
e in che modo le cose sono diverse oggi con
il trattamento dell'azione, della pratica e del
know-how non lo so che dire negli
helmholtzee nei giorni o anche nelle
tradizioni antiche o nella conoscenza del mondo
Quindi va bene così l'idea
Penso che
um
c'è una tendenza da uh è una
tendenza da una filosofia molto moderna
ma è stato molto influente nella
prima ondata di scienze cognitive a pensare
alla percezione come
una capacità di categorizzare l'ambiente
e di offrire una discreta  descrizione degli
aspetti ambientali quindi per esempio
percepire che uh il il
che so il la tazza è alla mia sinistra
è questione di sapere che c'è
qualcosa con ricerche tali proprietà per
la mia sinistra e questa è una specie di uh so
che una sorta di atteggiamento proposizionale nei
confronti del mondo, quindi
penso che la
cosa interessante di un attivismo e anche
della psicologia ecologica e nella
misura in cui ricordano il
pragmatismo americano dall'inizio di  il
secolo è pensare alla
percezione come a una questione di non
classificare queste grandi proprietà
nel mondo ma come rivelare
possibilità di agire
e questo è qualcosa che se dovessimo
spiegare che in termini di uh in
termini epidemici come la conoscenza lo saremmo '
Mettiamola come una questione di sapere che la
curva è alla mia sinistra ma di sapere come
afferrare la tazza e farne quello che
voglio se voglio bere una tazza di
caffè o se voglio usarla come
fermacarte avrà diverse
proprietà silenziose e questo è qualcosa
che,
sebbene sia stato, penso
molto, penso che un attivismo e una
psicologia ecologica e altre visioni incarnate della
cognizione siano state in gran parte con successo
in shif  Portando questa discussione a questo
punto penso che nelle scienze cognitive più
tradizionali tu
abbia ancora l'idea che bene gli
organismi organismi percepiti
descrivendo il modo in cui l'ambiente
questo è qualcosa che penso che
letture più tradizionali
dell'elaborazione predittiva rendano chiaro
come in uh l'idea che stai deducendo
sulla fonte degli stimoli e non
in uh e non e questo non è intendo
questo è più facilmente riconducibile all'idea
che il cervello o il
sistema cognitivo sappia che
il mondo è  così e così
l'ambiente è così e così invece di
dire che il sistema dell'agenda sa
come interagire con il mondo e credo che
il punto che
un attivista e uh
psicologi ecologici stanno cercando di fare
è lavorare anche sul predittivo
la codifica e il principio dell'energia libera
Etc è mostrare che queste nozioni questi
Framework potrebbero essere un'idea minima che
il sistema kubernetes sa come
impegnarsi sa come enga  ge
nell'ambiente in un modo in cui non ha bisogno di
essere letto nel riassunto interno
che il sistema Kindle sta deducendo
che il mondo è così quindi penso che questo sia
un modo per spiegare ma anche
filosoficamente se hai un grande
all'inizio di  negli ultimi
decenni una gigantesca discussione sul
fatto che nessun Cloud possa essere ridotto per
sapere che e poi di nuovo hai un
background di questo e dell'altro
come nozione indipendente da te lo
sai e se potresti
ridurre l'uno all'altro e così via  quindi
penso che non si fermi qui, non puoi
uh anche se posso fare una pretesa per la
percezione di qualcun altro sapendo
come sono ancora il problema
di fondo del fatto che il know-how possa essere trattato come
e tutto il
resto comunque questo è qualcosa che  Ci sto anche
lavorando di recente
c'è molto da dire
è un'idea così interessante soprattutto con la
comunicazione linguistica è un
po' come il dito e la luna e si
parla della luna ma il dito è
solo  dove si trova e non stiamo
parlando del puntatore stiamo parlando
del riferimento
e quindi di usare
una forma di comunicazione sociocognitiva
in un linguaggio colto
o in un discorso accademico scritto per scrutare
attraverso quello o reimmaginarlo e
vedere anche ciò che sembra  essere come l'
apice di saperlo
e ancora vederlo come sapere come
immagino che la domanda sia
come leggiamo i documenti
sì certo sì penso che sia uh è
un
uh è sì i valori sembra essere in
grado di essere  un problema molto grande perché se
proviamo a trattare queste
capacità negative come hai detto per una questione
di know-
how sembra che ci sfugga ancora qualcosa
della comunicazione per esempio e
d'altra parte penso e questa è la mia
intuizione ma penso  che potremmo in
linea di principio parlare di
come
capire ciò che hai appena detto e
cercare di rispondervi sia una questione di
sapere come comportarsi linguisticamente
ma penso che anche questo movimento
per trattare alti livelli di cognizionisti
che mi ha fatto  t una questione di know-how
omette ancora qualcosa in cui
mi trovo Intendo personalmente sono
e soddisfatto penso che a un certo
livello dobbiamo dirlo bene, questo è
un altro tipo di approccio che è necessario
qui per spiegare come  comunicare ad
esempio in modo
molto adeguato per non dire che
non coinvolge e ora ma non è solo
che penso che sia necessaria almeno più della
conoscenza pratica,
ma forse la chiave qui è pensare alla
conoscenza pratica solo di base e
necessaria per altri tipi  di altri altri
tipi di conoscenza di cui sono necessari
per impegnarsi in questo tipo di scambio
forse forse questo è uno
strato sono sicuro che
bisogna
dire altro su questo per dare una
risposta più informativa ma questo è un a
almeno la mia posizione attuale è che in
nessun modo fornisce la base del nostro
impegno con il mondo e con gli
altri, ma a un certo punto
dobbiamo essere in grado di sviluppare altri tipi di
comprensione per spiegare molto spiegare
i complessi tipi di uh  scambi che
abbiamo nella nostra vita quotidiana
come leggere documenti come hai detto
Sono d'accordo Penso che
inquadrare il sapere che come base e poi
recuperare il know-how è una sfida ed
è anche una sfida iniziare con i
processi cognitivi basali come
agiti senza casa e  riassemblare quei
pezzi di know-how per sapere che di
nuovo non è necessariamente nemmeno una semplice
sfida, ma preferiremmo affrontare
la sfida di assemblare processi cognitivi simbolici
proposizionali dichiarativi verbali
Etc da un
approccio cognitivo ecologico più liminale
o cercare di recuperare l'ecologico
dal turing  macchina in un certo senso quindi
sembra che
tu stia parlando a sostegno del radicamento
in processi cognitivi basali plausibili ecologici
e poi lavorando per
assemblare il grattacielo
sì sì sì totalmente sì penso che sia
bene
entrambi
uh entrambi gli approcci sono difficili
da assemblare  come hai detto a per
fornire questo tipo di spiegazione in
basso a sinistra o in alto in basso, ma io  ovviamente sono più
favorevole all'approccio web
penso che anche per un altro
motivo sembra che il punto
di partenza sia
una descrizione biologica di come
interagiamo con il mondo e
viceversa sembra essere molto più
difficile  per spiegare come arriviamo
a queste domande biologiche
come la morfologia del nostro corpo e simili sembra
che dobbiamo prima rendertene conto
e poi arriviamo alle altre
domande a cui è anche difficile
rispondere ma proprio al momento  almeno penso
che sia
un approccio dal basso verso l'alto è più
integrativo in un certo senso è che è
probabile che sembri essere più
a nostro favore nel senso
e e il modo in cui l'hai inquadrato
mi ha fatto pensare che se lo fossi  per
programmare un computer da
zero potrebbe essere un computer astratto o virtuale
quindi non ha nemmeno bisogno di avere
una forma di realizzazione specifica
e in quella situazione ci si potrebbe
preoccupare di assemblare
sapere che affermare che e assemblare
questi dichiara  affermazioni attive
e processi logici in
qualcosa che è più dinamico o
nell'interazione con l'ambiente, tuttavia
quel processo come l'ingegneria dello stack completo
con logica e silicone alla base
è abbastanza diverso da come siamo arrivati ​​​​qui
e quindi potrebbe ma è
complementare
ehm bene  hai dato un po' di visibilità
su uh, immagino il prima, durante e
dopo la revisione tra pari, quindi ero solo
curioso di sapere cosa è
cambiato durante e dopo l'articolo come
negli ultimi mesi o anni o per quanto
tempo fosse come ti sei evoluto su questo
e poi cosa  vedi come rilevanti i
prossimi passi se sono per te o
semplicemente generali da fare stiamo
cercando una misurazione del cervello stiamo
cercando una videocamera in una foresta stiamo
cercando un avanzamento concettuale cosa
andrà avanti oltre  i tuoi
sviluppi questa è un'ottima domanda penso
um
io non sono completamente soddisfatto del
modo in cui userò il livello straniero non
so se questo qualcuno di questi sarebbe
effettuato  t in uh onestamente non so
se in linea di principio potresti svolgere in
altri termini empirici ma
uh non sto dicendo che uh beh
uno è che lo scriverei un po '
diverso oggi non che non sia
che non sono d'accordo con il  carta
originariamente ma penso che
ci sia qualcosa in alcuni punti che
vorrei riformulare ma non
autorizzano nemmeno penso che avesse una nuova
carta
ma forse in futuro ma questo è
qualcosa che
le domande come il mito hanno
dato che è  ancora la domanda filosofica
e quella concettuale mi danno ancora
fastidio ma devo
ancora trovare l'opportunità di sviluppare queste
idee più attentamente e il punto di vista generale che
ho esposto lì penso penso che
sia ancora valido
uh ma
mi piacerebbe  ancora sto aspettando
questa occasione per elaborarla ulteriormente e
vedere fino a dove posso arrivare ma non lo so
ancora devo ammettere che non so quali sono
gli sviluppi futuri di questa idea
ma sto lavorando  su diverse
questioni isolate  s su questo approccio
negli ultimi anni ho lavorato con
la nozione di informazione e
comprensione scientifica e informazione per
attivisti ecologici e di
combinazione e recentemente sto lavorando
più recentemente con alcuni college sulla
realtà virtuale e il
riconoscimento della percezione, quindi uh
questo  è come mi piace condurre la mia
ricerca per
trovare domande interessanti e vedere come posso
affrontarle ma non necessariamente
trovarmi legato a
una linea di ragionamento in quel modo, quindi questo
è quello che è successo quando stavo
lavorando con  razionalità se pensassi che
fosse un argomento molto interessante e uh penso ancora
che lo sia ma non ho avuto il tempo
di tornare e riformulare quello che
volevo ma uh forse forse nel
prossimo futuro non lo so ma di più  la
cosa più recente su cui ho lavorato
non riguarda la
razionalità cellulare ma penso che alcuni prodotti
potrebbero essere sbagliati che è quello di una
realtà virtuale e
come si confronta effettivamente la realtà visiva
con com  binazione perché
beh c'è ovviamente qualcosa che manca
da una perseveranza e da un
ambiente visivo giusto
um c'è ovviamente se io qualcuno per
esempio se se mi trovo in un
ambiente visivo in cui sono sotto una sorta di
minaccia potrei provare qualcosa di analogo alla
paura ma  Non sto davvero temendo per la mia
vita
e immagino che la persona nella
realtà virtuale sia così razionale
scappare dalla
minaccia la minaccia virtuale e così
via così via questo è questo il questo è
quello che sto lavorando  su e uh forse
fornisce un punto di ritorno a questo
l'idea di
razionalità radicale e attiva e infatti uh il giornale è
appena stato accettato così come ti dicevo
prima ero così impegnato in questi ultimi
giorni perché stavamo correggendo le prove il
mio  io e i colleghi non ho mai immaginato
uh e
anch'io avevo un programma serrato
per presentare la versione corretta del
paper nelle ultime settimane e poi ho
ottenuto le bozze e
oh
uh beh forse uh in futuro posso
tornare sull'iss  ue di razionalità
mi piacerebbe ma non so se
non lo so proprio non riesco a prevederne gli
sviluppi ma in generale
concordo ancora con la mia idea originale ma la
inquadrerò un po' diversamente  un po'
così il punto VR sono sicuro che c'è
molto altro da dire lì, ma mi ha ricordato
solo il titolo realtà virtuale è una
virtualizzazione e quindi allo stesso modo in
cui
la pianificazione dell'azione cognitiva
ci consente di intrattenere
politiche che il nostro corpo non fa  ci vuole anche
solo per valutarli e scegliere
contro di loro, ma possiamo andare su un volo
di fantasia avere un processo di selezione politica stravagante
di controfattuali
mentalmente,
ma poi la nostra morfologia è un po' come la
nostra ancora di salvezza sai se
cadi davvero da una sporgenza allora è  ti farà male
e poi nella realtà virtuale
sei incarnato
l'esperienza percettiva è letteralmente
una virtualizzazione di
situazioni critiche di sopravvivenza, quindi
potresti vederti come su una sporgenza
ma sei su un pavimento piatto
e quindi in quella situazione
se sei una specie di
osservatore cognitivo al di fuori del
videogioco potresti dire bene che è
razionale per me cadere per vedere
cosa succede
quindi è come ma poi c'è uno strato
di razionalità all'interno dello spazio sì come
qual è una buona mossa  nel gioco
um e quindi è un po' offuscare il confine
tra
[Musica
] è offuscare la criticità
del corpo e
um sono sicuro che ci hai pensato molto di
più, quindi come si gioca nella nostra
realtà virtuale
um con il  modi in cui pensiamo, usiamo
e progettiamo bene questi sistemi
questo è il il il le le
domande che ci hanno motivato a scrivere un
documento e uh NADA gliele abbiamo date e io ero
che nella letteratura tecnica si vede
che molti ricercatori che lavorano con
il  tratta la percezione visiva come
una sorta di illusione, ma questo ci ha
un po' infastidito perché d'
altra parte funziona solo in VR perché
abbiamo incarnato i dispositivi i dispositivi
funzionano per noi hai i controller
hai la testa  impostato
e uh sembra così strano dire che l'
utente l'utente è sotto una sorta di
illusione
e d'altra parte sembra che
non sia effettivamente cognitivo perché come hai
detto non c'è non c'è nessuna
rilevanza biologica per quelli uh cognitivo
Afferma per così dire, ad esempio, se vedo
una mela in VR è che non si
nutre ma ha senso all'interno del
gioco, ma il diverso uh
beh ho ricevuto una mela in un
ambiente reale è che fornisce
nutrimento  è qualcosa che posso mangiare
ma non in VR posso fingere di farlo quindi abbiamo
coniato questo concetto di allusione al
suo piano
è come se fossimo di
fronte a un animale reale ma implica
anche questa volizione di giocare questa idea
che non siamo
essere fuorviato perché indossiamo l'
attrezzatura che sappiamo di essere nel gioco e
questo penso sia un argomento caldo in questo momento
perché ci sono metafore e sono molto
scettico su tutto ciò
che può le persone sono molto ottimiste ma
sulle possibilità del metave  rse
e alcuni autori pensano davvero che
potremmo essere in una simulazione in
senso stretto, ma intendo dire che la migliore
tecnologia che la tecnologia attuale
ci mostra è che è molto limitata e puoi
fingere di essere in un certo ambiente
e così via e questo penso  può
offrire nuovi modi di
pensare alla razionalità in questo
ambiente visivo in modi in cui forse i
russi fanno qualcosa che l'ambiente
ha detto per saltare giù dalla sporgenza e vedere
cosa succede e, d'altra parte
, gli aspetti comportamentali di farlo a volte le
persone si sentono davvero  la paura e le persone
affrontano la strada per le fobie con la realtà virtuale
e
um è un sacco di ci sono un sacco di
domande interessanti lì che
forse intendo per la ricerca futura possiamo
sì tornarci su, mi ha fatto pensare a
come la Apple nella vita reale  potrebbero essere
calorie per te ma potrebbero anche essere
calorie per una mosca potrebbe essere lanciata
potresti usarlo come un martello potresti
dipingerlo bene quindi l'
ecologia e il generativo  processo come
diremmo che un tipo di inferenza attiva
va sempre al di là di
qualunque accessibilità sia stata programmata
per un dato oggetto e poi anche
l'attuale discorso sulla VR si concentra
fortemente sulle
cuffie parlando in modo totalmente aneddoticamente
non la mia area di esperti
um sembra un  un po' interessante
è come se la
discussione sul cellulare fosse focalizzata solo su
rettangoli di una certa dimensione
ciò che rende questa realtà non virtuale è
come guardare attraverso una finestra e
c'è un altro con cui parlare
quindi non è attaccato alla mia testa non è così
abbiamo alcune delle
capacità di tracciamento del movimento che alcune tecnologie
hanno, ma è
una modifica di nicchia nello spazio personale di Perry
e possiamo inviare
segnali e offerte l'uno all'altro,
quindi avere un inquadramento VR o davvero solo un
inquadramento di razionalità e
cognizione percettiva Cicli d'azione
che
non sono solo vincolati a una
realizzazione specifica o a un tipo di hardware e possono eseguire
la gamma da Total offline
persona in un campo
a s  qualcuno che è molto
in The Matrix
sembra piuttosto rilevante altrimenti le nuove
tecnologie anche piccole varianti e
aggiornamenti software continueranno a
sorprendere e confondere infinitamente
sì, penso che sia un è difficile
definire i confini
Voglio dire che siamo qui ehm in uno scambio
che  Penso che potrebbe aumentare ma essere
classificato come una forma di realtà
virtuale ovviamente ti vedo rovinare la tua
mente C ma
intendo dire che la maggior parte penso funzioni che al
giorno d'oggi lo trovano un documento
dicendo che beh devono avere un auricolare  e a
volte un controller, ma
a parte questo suona realtà virtuale ma
sì, è difficile definire qualcosa
, non è non è una discarica e
semplice, è una delle cose
perché parlare in modo commerciale
ovviamente realtà virtuale significa cuffie
e altri accessori ma ma  un
telefono solo parlando al telefono o un
telegrafo in quel momento sarebbe
stato su quell'interfaccia con quella
modalità sensoriale e con quelle affordances
è  la virtualizzazione
sì a cui abbiamo accesso solo a un
capitolo diverso oggi
sì, penso di sì, parte del nostro articolo
era di sostenere che in un certo senso l'incarnazione
dei dispositivi tecnologici è ovviamente
nella necessità non non è una novità è il
segno dell'essere umano
è  incarnare dispositivi tecnologici
ciò che ci ha reso ciò che siamo sin
dall'inizio utilizzando la tecnologia analitica e
il fatto che possiamo incarnarla in modo così
abilmente un dispositivo anche se è
programmato per esempio all'interno
della realtà virtuale per avere qualcosa di cui una
creatura ci controlli più ricchi  nuova
morfologia un'altra morfologia per
esempio anche se è così, succede solo in
modo così abilmente perché siamo in
grado di incarnare il dispositivo alcuni
esperimenti hanno dimostrato che puoi mappare
ad esempio una torsione del polso su un
terzo braccio
uh che la realtà individuale va da era
che dal tuo petto e le persone possono
imparare a controllare questo terzo braccio che
non si adatta alla nostra morfologia attuale
ma può essere reso tale da un Twist o  f il
polso, quindi
questo è qualcosa di cui parleremo nel
nostro articolo che bene
puoi farlo solo perché incarni
il dispositivo puoi vedere che è
un'illusione in realtà fa
parte di ciò che io sono essere umano è
ricamare dispositivi tecnologici quindi
io  andrebbe in quel modo voglio dire lo so che
offusca la distinzione tra
gemme virtuali e non virtuali penso che sia un
modo di affrontare questo
fantastico c'è qualcos'altro di cui vuoi
parlare chiedi o solo una specie di preludio
ah beh lo farei  vorrei ringraziarti per l'
opportunità di discutere questo documento è stato
molto bello per me mi è davvero piaciuto
e questo è un ambiente molto bello e
confortevole per discutere questi
problemi e pensare grazie ancora una volta
grazie sì discussione fantastica e
argomenti importanti e  saremo felici di
parlare con te di nuovo in qualsiasi momento
ok grazie addio grazie